what's up YouTube welcome to another
YouTube live happy to be here every
Thursday try to make the commitment to
be with you once a week to answer
questions help you with your business so
join on in give me some questions this
is an AMA format whatever is on your
mind I want to be able to help with
today I'm also vlogging so I've got a
vlogging crew with me and they're behind
the scenes you can't actually see them
they're like right there and right there
so I want to help you out I want to give
you some guidance as we normally do on
Thursdays so come into the chat I see
bunch people joining and already welcome
positive Academy welcome Lily you guys
can say hi I love the highs but most
importantly I want to get to your
questions so you have something you want
to hit me up with let me know welcome
aboard
Rahul welcome fan of Cristiano Ronaldo
first viewer welcome Simon hi Evan I
reached out to you on Twitter and regard
to an opportunity might be interested in
you mentioned I should join you live so
here I am great that was a long message
Simon what do you want to talk about
let's go Shahrukh Khan how do you
inspire yourself how to inspire myself
it starts with having a routine that
supports me and builds me up and then an
environment so as an example I
understand my one word is belief I want
more belief in my life I try to
reverse-engineer that and figure out how
do I bring more belief daily when I walk
into this office here it's automatic
belief for me these people may not mean
much to you you probably know this guy
you probably don't know the middle three
and you probably know the guy in the end
they may not be super meaningful to you
but they're meaningful to me so one of
the advantages of creating an
environment for yourself is that it
happens automatically so you don't have
to wake up and think about how are you
going to be inspired it happens
automatically because of the one time
effort you go and put into building an
environment so that super helpful most
environments suck especially physical
environments so think about what's on
your walls on your desk what's around
you where you are you don't have to be
living in a luxury penthouse apartment
it could just be a picture in the wall
makes all the difference and to then you
habits your habits your routines what
are you doing to surround yourself with
that vibe that you need on a regular
basis so for me I'm very blessed that I
have a lot of people in my life who
support
me who want me to win who cheer me on
think I'm doing a great job the downside
of that is there's nobody pushing me to
do more there's nobody saying Evan what
you've done is okay but I know you can
do a lot more like who's giving me the
push forward I don't have that physical
person in my life anymore
and so I get it by looking at the
stories of these famous entrepreneurs
when I see Elon Musk talking about
having a back-up plan for Humanity and
wanting to go to Mars to do that it
makes me think like I'm not playing a
big enough game right my friends might
think I'm playing a huge game even if I
think I'm playing a big game then when I
surround myself with people who are
playing a much bigger one it motivates
me to want to go off and do more I use
it as positive motivation not as a kick
down but a kick forward not as I can
never do what Elon Musk does but as a
that's inspiring I want to go off and
give my best and do more and so for me
it's reading one page from my book every
morning and then doing a video and and
then it's watching the videos of these
successful people who've done amazing
things that that sets me up every day
and so it's just understanding what is
it that gets you fired up what what is
it that gets you motivated on a regular
basis and putting that into your morning
routine doing down on an everyday basis
instead of hoping that randomly in a
Thursday afternoon and you're gonna get
inspired by somebody and then you're on
fire for the rest of the day you want to
bring that into your morning routine
every single day it doesn't really
matter what I do to inspire myself like
that doesn't really help you that much
what's more important is what inspires
you and here's the thing you already
know it you've already done it you've
been inspired at some point in your life
right you have been inspired something
got you inspired a conversation a book a
podcast a video a movie something
inspired you and so if you just think
back to when you have been inspired and
now planned that into your morning
routine instead of randomly waiting for
it to happen that's when a lot starts to
change in your life if you woke up and
did the thing that made you feel bold
every single morning your life would not
look the same or anywhere close to it
one year from today if you did that
every single day for a year your life
will be unrecognizable where you are
right now
lot of questions coming in guys if you
tagged me it's a lot easier for me to
see dirty mint Evan did you learn coding
or programming not really I can hack my
way through a bunch I'm I'm enough to be
dangerous on tools like Photoshop but
I'm not an expert with with HTML and
some coding I know enough to edit code
and just understand how it works so if I
look at it it's not total gibberish to
me but I never went to school to really
learn it I haven't really focused on
getting better at learning it I just
want to have an understanding of how my
business runs if you have an
understanding of how your business runs
and you can you can be dangerous right
and you can help guide the process so
I'm really great at coming up with
creative ideas to make things better but
I need to have a general understanding
to be able to make it better if I have
no idea that I'm just leaving it in the
hands of somebody else so it's a
vulnerability and I wanted to improve it
and even even now like for making videos
I am NOT the best editor and I'm not the
best cameraman and I don't know all the
gear and all the technology and which
microphone I should use but I know
enough about things to make decent
enough videos and be dangerous so I
don't need to be the expert at
everything but I want to understand how
my business works
ok next lots of questions coming in
Michelle Evan how do you balance
everything that goes on in your life
when you have a day job and trying to
start a business alongside alongside
balancing family fitness goals etc so
we're filming a vlog today you can watch
the vlog it'll document how I manage my
life right guys they're over here
they're behind the scenes you can't see
them ninjas
listen I think if you if you're trying
to balance being an entrepreneur and and
having a job the most important thing
that you need to do is keep the momentum
going every single day for the days that
the work is really hard and you're
you're working really late still finding
time at least 20-30 minutes every single
day to build momentum the biggest
mistake most of those entrepreneurs make
is they start and they stop and they
start and they stop and they start and
they stop and you're working really hard
on one Saturday afternoon for four hours
and then you don't work until the next
Saturday afternoon you lose too much
momentum in between for the business
like actual real momentum and just for
yourself to feel like you're
something that is meaningful and
important and so if this is a passion of
yours that you want to build up you need
to dedicate the time to it not massive
chunks every single day but something
has to get done every single day for the
things are important in your life so if
your business is important you need to
spend at least half an hour every single
day if if your relationship is important
right and you're your husband or your
wife you need to spend time every day it
may not you may not want to spend five
hours a day with your husband or wife
every day but if you're not checking in
if you're not spending 20 30 40 50 60
minutes quality time with that person
your relationships going to deteriorate
deteriorate doing one meeting with your
with your husband every Saturday and
that's how you're gonna build a
relationship it's not gonna work out and
so it's the same thing in business if
you're not spending quality time at
least a little bit every single day to
keep the momentum growing you're gonna
lose and so some days might be more but
just making sure that every single day
you're spending some time to build the
momentum grow lots of questions is
awesome thanks guys ap where can I find
people to buy my business and invention
ideas so first off if you're only gonna
sell the invention and the idea you need
a patent people will not just buy your
idea the first thing that a business
will do if you're trying to sell it to
them is the look at their technology
department and they'll say how long does
it take us to recreate this and if it's
gonna take them you know three months to
do what you did or six months and they
have tons of resources they're not gonna
pay you to do it they're just going to
do it themselves unless they really
value that three or six month time the
market advantage so you need a patent
you need something that's defensible the
best way to be able to do it is if you
can partner up with a lawyer who also
has connections to be able to help you
sell the patent so the advantage of
going with a bigger firm to get your
patent done is they have clients in the
field who might be interested in
licensing or buying the patent the
advantage of hiring a great lawyer
is not just getting legal advice it's
the connections great lawyers help their
clients win in business beyond just
giving legal advice and so if I'm you
I'm looking to work with a patent
attorney who's part of a big firm who is
willing to work with me who sees you as
a source of ongoing ideas and leads and
generation
and creativity that then I'm forming a
long-term relationship with you're gonna
be the one coming with the ideas they're
gonna be the ones in the patent and
hopefully introducing you to the right
people to help to start to monetize it
if the lawyer looks at you and they see
a one-off thing it's not as exciting if
they see that you are a flow of
creativity forever and ever then becomes
a lot more interesting for them to want
to do a deal with you next paradigm
shift travels what have you learned that
has motivated you the most what what
quote keeps you motivated so there's no
one single quote that keeps me motivated
I think I think if you rely on one quote
that constant keep you motivated I think
you're gonna lose I think the more you
could have a favorite movie of all time
that got you inspired - Seabiscuit
I have it on my shelf back there I've
watched it you know 20 30 times but you
can't just keep going back to the same
quote over and over and over and over
and over again I think more important
than having one quote or one video is
that you have a steady stream that is
along the along the same line of
thinking so example if you watch a
motivational video the first time you
watch it you might be really inspired
like wow that's really amazing and then
if you watch it again you still might be
inspired but nowhere near the same as
the first time every single time you
watch it again you lose some of how
important that message hits with gets to
the point where if you do it every day
it'll lose like it won't touch you at
all anymore you'll be you'll be thinking
of something else where you're watching
video you'll be checking your email
you'll be distracted because you already
know it's coming and it's not
interesting anymore now if you watch the
same video a year later maybe because
you haven't watched in a while has some
kind of impact so much more important
than watching the same video over and
over again or looking at the same quote
over and over and over again is having a
steady source so for me I use my own
YouTube channel it's not watching the
same Steve Jobs video a thousand times
it's here is great advice from so many
different entrepreneurs that every day
there's new content that I can learn
from so I'm making three videos a day
almost every day there's always a new
video for you to watch but it doesn't
have to be me it could be a podcast it
could be an author not just a book and
author right you can't just read the
same book over and over and over and
over again that's why I want people to
read one page a day
the top ten rows a success because
there's 400 rules you get two rules per
day so let's take you 200 days to get to
the book then you can start over again
200 days where if you keep doing the
same thing over and over and over again
it'll lose its efficacy so find the
source that gets you motivated the most
and incorporate that into your daily
basis next see JD Evan thoughts on
Shopify drop shipping full time it's
just a business model lots of business
models gonna work you can have the
skills to develop it pretty quickly you
can understand how to you know reverse
engineer the algorithms to rank and the
ins and outs of Shopify and which is the
best drop shipping company to work with
it's a business model and any business
model can work what's more important is
do you love the product you're selling
are you trying to build a community and
customer base for life right if you're
physically and emotionally attached to
the thing you're creating you're
ultimately gonna win long term if you're
doing it just as a business model then
then you're gonna lose so any business
model can work every single business
model can work I'm not attached to the
business model I'm attached to what I'm
attached to right get attached to what
you're actually attached to sell stuff
that means something to you that's when
you're gonna win the lot J with a $7
super chat thank you the law J the next
two coffees are on you I appreciate it
what is the best way to make like-minded
friends uh-huh that is an amazing
question I think as adults as we get
older we stop making friends especially
entrepreneurs we you know start our own
business it's a lonely game we might
eventually build a team of employees but
they may not be the best friends to be
able to connect with I think just like
what you did when you were younger you
expose yourself to opportunities you
were going to class you were kind of
forced to do it you had to go to class
and you had to do sports and you had to
take music and you have to do all these
different things now it's doing it with
intention so one of the greatest reasons
why people join my day in school the
company I invested in is to make friends
like sure they want to learn how to
dance but learning how to dance salsa is
not really a massively practical thing
to know it's not the most essential
skill that you need to learn so
why does so many people want to come and
do it well it's because they want
connection they want to meet people they
want to learn something new and they
want to check something off their bucket
list people are looking for a place to
belong and they're not getting that a
lot in their life and in that whoever
they're working so finding a way to say
yes to things like whatever is
interesting for you if you want to be a
videographer go look at any videography
kind of meetups or clubs or events and
make some new friends say hello
introduce yourself if you want to be an
entrepreneur go look at people who want
to become entrepreneurs again meetups
events things that are happening in the
community
it could be online right so through this
we have a great community of people who
try to help each other out but I think a
lot of people need the human one-on-one
personal connection as well and so
finding something that's happening in
your local community or creating one
yourself for people who are like-minded
to try to attract those people in it's
really just having a dedicated effort to
say I'm going to find people who I want
to connect with and I'm gonna say yes to
different opportunities so I would be
evaluating how are you spending your
evenings how are you spending your
weekends how many of those things are
just doing the same thing over and over
and over and over again versus I'm out
joining a new club trying out a new
place saying yes to a new activity or
opportunity right the more you're doing
that the more you're gonna find those
like-minded people next CJD asking lots
of questions today do you think going to
colleges do you think going to college
is worthwhile to do if you want to be an
entrepreneur so let me answer this as
truthfully and honestly as I can first I
think a college degree is a fantastic
back-up plan so I think if you if you
are at all worried that you might not
make it as an entrepreneur that you
might have to go get a job and you're
not a hundred percent sure then having a
degree definitely helps you get a better
job when I started off when my business
I didn't know that entrepreneurship was
for me and I I did not drop out of
school even though I started my business
while I was in university I wasn't Hynde
percent sure and so I wanted to have
that back-up plan
I only got the The Bachelor the
undergrad degree I didn't go for more
education by that point I kind of felt
like
okay I know this is for me but if you
have any lack of certainty or clarity it
could be helpful as a back-up plan so
that's point number one two is just seen
can you use the college at all to help
you grow your business is there any
point in being in college that can be a
jump step for you to actually do your
business so as an example my company my
first business when I was in university
we sold two universities part of our
customer base were universities and so I
was able to go and talk to University
potential clients as a university
student and do some research project
around it and make introductions where
if I was coming in as a private company
from the outside it would have been more
difficult and so there might be past you
can use your university degree and the
education process through it to be able
to actually help you build and grow your
business at the same time so I don't
know that that value is enough to do it
but it can definitely be helpful for you
and really I go in thinking it primarily
as a back-up plan for taking a corporate
job so that's the honest truth for me
next AP if I don't have the money to buy
a hundred patents what should I do
can't I just sign a nondisclosure
agreement before I share my D and
selling them there's a law
first off non-disclosure agreements is a
lot of ways through them and to most
companies will not sign a nondisclosure
agreement with you so if somebody it's a
big company with a lot of money you're
trying to sell your idea to Coke or or
McDonald's or Tesla or like whoever it
is that you want to be able to sell a
lot to they're not signing your
non-disclosure agreement like VCS
venture capitalists will not sign a
nondisclosure agreement because they see
some winning ideas and you need to also
understand that most of the time the
idea is not enough most of the time what
you think is such a great idea they've
already thought of some variation of it
they've already thought about it
what they lack is the execution so if
you can come and bring them execution
and show them how they can actually win
you're going to be a part of the
solution you're not just gonna give them
an idea and take away like
leave and go do something else it's all
on them if you want to introduce a
revolutionary idea to a company but they
have to do all the work around it it's
really hard to move them forward because
they're slow they don't like taking big
change they don't like having to invest
into a whole new thing they don't like
doing it it's really difficult so the
more you can bring execution alongside
it really helps to but you could try the
non-disclosure agreement
you probably just won't get very far and
dealing with big companies around it
Liz J Evan do you think it's okay to
have more than one business so listen
that's a judgment call I'm not gonna
tell you if it's ok or not like that
that's a personal issue it's a personal
question for you is it the best decision
in terms of getting a result probably
not a lot of times if you want to go far
if you're being split between multiple
businesses especially if they're in
different industries and are not
complementary to each other you will get
better results by being specific being
niche building one business up and then
trying to find ways to to bring in a
product line expansion a business
expansion finding ways to make it work
together as opposed to trying to have to
do two different business at the same
time it's hard enough to run one
business like as an entrepreneur
starting a business is going to be one
of the most difficult things you ever
have to do in your life and it's hard
enough to run one business let alone
doing two at the same time and so all
the admin work and all the crap that you
hate doing now gets amplified twice you
need two websites and you need social
media accounts for two companies across
how many different platform then you
need accounting for two companies all of
this stuff amplified out and you end up
being drowned in paperwork more often
than not which is not what you want to
do as an entrepreneur so focus is super
important whatever extra time you have I
would try to put it into one company
that ideally does both things like find
out the things that you're so great at
that only you can do and make that one
business instead of trying to do two
dave night doing the $1.99 super chat
thank you for the love Dave next
coffee's on you heaven can you share how
to set goals I'm really weird about this
we talked about this on my vlog earlier
on you'll see it when it comes on the on
the
I I have a long-term forever goal my
goal is to help solve the world's
biggest problem untapped human potential
I'm never gonna reach my goal I've set a
goal beyond my capacity to be able to go
out and fill I'm never gonna get it it's
it's not possible and I like that I like
having something that I'm chasing down
that is not possible to accomplish so I
have that
that's my lifetime goal that's what I
wake up I want to have a big impact
every single day from there I just have
goals that I've set that are that are
short-term that are what's happened in
next couple months I think if you know
where you're gonna be in five years and
you're thinking too small
everything that I've done in the past
five years I never would have said I
would be at five years ago my channel
had had 7000 subscribers four years ago
and now I'm at 1.3 million I said I
would never write a book I've done two
books a lot of the stuff that was never
in my radar I've done and I think when
you set five-year goals for yourself one
you're thinking small and two you've
booked yourself in that you're you're
stifling your own creativity you don't
know where you're gonna be in five years
so stop trying to plan for it instead I
think we're done what am i working on
right now and how does that help me
accomplish my big vision of solving the
world's biggest problem so that's my
approach different than most next you go
$5.00 super chat appreciate it that's
that's two coffees on you what's your
advice on building an online brain
physical products at the same time
working a 12-hour job and keeping your
wife from from feeling put aside so
similar answer to what I said before you
need to make sure you're dedicating time
every single day for both for your
business for you know your obviously
your career what you're doing right now
and also for your wife if you are not
spending at least half an hour every
single day of quality time with your
business it's going to fail with your
wife your relationships gonna fail I
need to figure what that balance is how
much time you need to spend with your
wife to make that work how much time you
spend with your business to make it work
I would do a really strong audit of
where your time is being spent and I
would I would challenge you to say
there's still probably a lot of waste of
time like every second has to count when
you've got lots of domains like that how
much time are you wasting on Facebook or
on Instagram or watching Netflix or
something that does not
help you achieve the goals that you're
trying to help a lot of people default
to saying I need to sleep an hour less I
don't think that's it in most cases I
think I could easily find an hour in
your day that you are just flat-out
wasting that if you were more cautious
with it you could sleep what you need
and spend the time with your wife and do
the work on your business and keep your
full-time job it may not be in the exact
amounts that you want yet but you can do
it just stop wasting time and make every
minute intentional the other thing that
I found really helps with the
relationship side is just involving my
wife in the decisions and interesting
what's happening just for her to know
what I'm dealing with if I'm stressed
out I'm sharing what I'm stressed out
about if I'm excited about something
I'll share what I'm excited about I'm
naturally not a sharer I don't need
anybody's validation to feel good or bad
about what I'm doing in my company so I
don't need to share anything this is
evolution I've had to do for the success
of my relationship because I don't feel
the need to share but she has the need
to understand so I need to understand
that and share so that she feels
connected to what I'm doing and so she's
involved in a lot of my video she was in
this you know this morning were vlogging
she was in the video we're doing a may
the fourth Chewbacca video tomorrow
she's in that and so involving her in
the business so she feels like it's a
part of her as well and she is to
contribute to it as opposed to my thing
that is separate and the involvement
could be on an actual like doing work in
the business being involved in pieces or
just an emotional involvement I want
that I want my wife emotionally involved
in my business because if she's not then
when the business is taking up a lot of
our time or domains then it's then it's
a conflict and it's my thing instead of
it being our thing
and then I think the last step for that
is just understanding where you're
putting your your reserves and having
emotional equity built up so as an
example when I get in the zone on
something I need to finish it in and my
wife gets a tan and they're saying that
when I get like laser focus on something
that thing has to happen and I'm gonna
push everything else aside to make that
happen so as an example to finish my
book the top 10 Rose a success I
on my cruise vacation out that I needed
to get it finished on the anniversary
date of my first book to make that
happen it meant like I had to work
really hard on my vacation to make that
happen and so while my wife was working
out I was working on the book while she
was sleeping I was working on the book
we still did vacation he stuff together
but I spent way more time than I
normally would working on the book and
she she understands that because when I
get in that zone then I have to get it
done how we made it all work was for the
moments that I'm not hyper focused on in
that zone I've done so much for the
relationship that I that I've made
deposits to our emotional bank account
but now I have to make withdrawals from
it because I need her support to allow
me to be able to finish this book
because if I'm trying to stay focusing
in the zone and she's upset at me and
she's not supportive it's gonna be
really hard for me to create something
amazing for you and if I was always
doing that and always neglecting her it
wouldn't work out right our relationship
would crumble but because I did so much
work on the peak points when I was not
focused on a project that consumed on my
time that allowed me to pull from our
emotional bank account so I'm depositing
as much as I can always because I know
when something big comes up I'm gonna
have to pull from it and and she's gonna
be on board and supporting next Simon
Rudd another $5 super chat thank you for
the love to more coffees on Simon I get
a lot of copies from you guys hi Evan I
noticed your website you were interested
in finding music I have lots to offer
what loved we'll discuss it with you
awesome semi send me some semi some
samples I mean your channel hit me up
email Evan Evan chemical comm send me
the music that you are most proud of
like this is Simon Rudd this is the
thing that you Mike my piece I'm most
proud of shooted over I want to see it
in general for anybody who's trying to
make a pitch who's trying to get noticed
who once again somebody's radar I always
encourage people to give a sample of
their best work like don't just tell
somebody hey I'm a great composer or hey
I'm a great sketch artist or hey I'm a
great videographer with that message
back always send what you are most proud
of that they can check out so having
some context on my channel knowing the
kind of thing that I like to put out
don't send me some crazy you know heavy
metal thing because I
not gonna use it right understanding my
channel and what you think would be a
good fit that you are most proud of it
makes it much easier for you to get a
yes versus everybody else so looking
forward I love working with people who
are part of believe nation if there's a
fit for what I'm doing so send it over
let's see what happens next pointless
and irrational wow that's that's quite
the name pointless and irrational so we
pay attention to this question is it
okay to do something you really disliked
to get what you love or should I just
risk it all and start the business I
really want here's the thing when you
get what you really like you're not
gonna like it like it's not about
achieving a goal the people who have the
most success enjoy the process to enjoy
doing the work if you are trying to do
something only to get a result you'll
almost never get there and if you do
it's really a small reflection of what
you could potentially get people say
I'll do whatever it takes to get there
but you won't and you'll get crushed by
the people who actually love doing it so
as an example you want to get a million
subscribers on YouTube great you want to
be the next youtuber getting a million
subscribers awesome if you don't enjoy
making videos you're done you'll you'll
start working and you'll beat yourself
up and you'll grind really hard but
you'll never actually create great work
because you don't like making videos so
stop doing that because the people who
love making videos will destroy you all
day long especially if you're just
getting started and you don't have the
skills or the talent yet much better is
to find a thing that you could be great
at find a thing that you have the
Michael Jordan level talent at and
nurture that talent and develop the
skills and get better and do the thing
that you enjoy doing and ultimately
you're gonna win people have a weird
fixation around money I don't think
people grow up with a healthy mindset
around money some people think money is
everything and that is that is a hollow
existence and one that's definitely not
true and then some people think that
money is the root of all evil and they
they shun money and then they end up
living far below what they could do in
terms of having an impact on this world
because they think money is is evil
it's not money is super important even
if you're a charity money is important
money is an exchange of
you in a business money is really
important it just can't be number one
there has to be something above money
for you for the people in this book for
the people on this wall for the whoever
your heroes are in life who've had
success money is important but it's not
number one so you've got to find the
thing that is more important than making
money and then find a way to do that add
value to others and make money in the
process if you are not enjoying the
process of the work you're doing you
will lose stop move on to the thing that
you actually enjoy doing doesn't it's
gonna work out right away but that's
ultimately how you win
sonic Lukas Evan I'm 24 years old I have
a few hundred dollars in my bank account
no job but I have a dream that I
strongly care to implement would you
recommend me would you recommend for me
to just go for it so I think this really
depends on your personality for one if
you don't do anything you will regret it
for the rest of your life it has nothing
to do with how much money you have in
your bank account or not you don't need
a ton of money to start a business I
actually recommend starting a business
without any money you will not know how
to make money to start so the more you
invest enter at the beginning the more
likely you're gonna lose
just drain your bank account and flat
out lose so don't spend your money don't
go into debt don't take on a huge
mortgage to start your business because
you will not know how to spend it
properly at the beginning but if this is
your dream 100% if you don't do
something you're gonna be 50 years old
look back in your life and and regret it
and say man I made a really stupid
decision and you've run out of time to
go off and actually do something about
it whether you go all-in or whether you
start part-time and work your way
through really is down to your
personality some people need to burn the
bridges burn the boats go cold turkey
like I'm gonna quit smoking by never
smoking again and just deciding and
that's it and some people can use
Nicorette and some people can wean
themselves off of it so if you're the
kind of personality that is extreme then
go for it do it if you can handle my
preferred way is not to go extreme
because you have a limited runway to do
it but you might have to make it work in
three months or you're you're out on the
street and you may not be able to get it
done in three months my preferred way if
you can handle the
have the patience for it is take a job
where you're gonna learn something
understand how your industry works and
start your business on the side every
evening every weekend on your lunch
breaks every change you get to build
your business and when your side hustle
your business on the side is giving you
enough money to support yourself not
make not make you know huge car payments
not buy a house but just support
yourself like you're paying your
internet bills you're paying your rent
then you can go full-time that's what I
would do but that's more my personality
but if you don't do something about it
guarantee 100% you will regret it when
you look back on your life so good luck
what do we got guys if you tagged me
it's alot easier to see the questions
nah loose nah less ooh nah less ooh I
want to be a journalist and everyone is
so negative about it especially about
the pay which we need to live what is my
passion how do I pursue it so there's a
lot of ways to win if you're a great
storyteller if you're a journalist it's
really about telling stories it doesn't
mean you have to be a reporter at a
typical news company you know there's
lots of people there's lots of people
who are reporters on YouTube and
reporters on their blog and reporters on
their website reporters on Twitter I'd
encourage you to expand your scope of
what being a reporter
looks like so you're not just kind of
boxed in second part though is who cares
what other people think like at what
point do you give yourself permission to
say this is my dream and I'm gonna chase
it so if your friends say go for it now
it makes sense to go for it you're
living your life according to them and
if your friends say no then then it's a
crappy idea like that's a terrible way
to live your friends don't want the same
thing that you want so their advice is
meaningless to you at the end of the day
similar to the last question if you
don't do this thing that's your dream
you're gonna regret that decision
forever most people most of your friends
are gonna end up in a job that they hate
they wake up and they drive to a job
that they hate that's most of North
America
so that's who you're taking advice from
if you don't want that then stop taking
advice from them right and at the end of
the day their opinions still don't mean
anything to you you don't need anybody's
permission it's funny how many people
you know ask questions and because I say
go for it now they go for it like you
never needed anybody
approval here you have permission I give
you all permission right now to go off
and do the thing that you want to do you
don't need anybody's approval this is
your life it's not my version of your
life or your parents or anybody else's
you want to do something find the
smallest possible way to start you want
to be reporter start reporting just
start start documenting stuff start
telling stories start making youtube
videos start a website start a vlog
start posting on LinkedIn or medium
start you could do it right now and the
more you create the more you are a
journalist the more you tell great
stories the more you improve your skills
and beat on your craft and the better
you get at it the more opportunities
will come your way whether that ends up
being working for a big company or you
find a different path like it's the
question of where you gonna be in five
years you don't know where you're gonna
be in five years
you have no idea how you're gonna evolve
in the next five years but I guarantee
you you'll be in the same spot you are
right now if you don't take any kind of
action so you have to do something so
start you don't need anybody's
permission just start make it better the
next day and better the next day and
better the next day
good luck kxly4 the startup seeking
funding to build a product you think I
should seek funding and focus on a
product to find another way to raise
money if you start trying to raise money
couple things one you will lose a lot of
the money because you don't know how to
spend it properly because it's your
first time through just like the first
time you do anything you suck at it you
don't know how to do it properly so you
will burn a lot of money doing the wrong
thing to you spend most your time trying
to raise money instead of actually
building a business and so for people
who are out there trying to raise
capital look at what's actually
happening in your business you are
killing the momentum of your company you
spend six months 12 months 18 months 24
months trying to raise capital in the
mean time nothing is happening in your
company much better is to actually start
building momentum if you are in the
startup phase and trying to raise
capital recognize that any investor
because it's so risky they're gonna take
a huge chunk your company it's too risky
for them so you're gonna lose a massive
amount of your company even if you got
somebody to say yes the best thing to do
is find the smallest possible way to get
started have the big dream the big
vision the big invention the changed
world mission amazing and then like what
do I do right now every single day if
I'm you if I'm 16 I'm trying to build my
company out right now with the resources
that I have right now if I'm looking to
raise money the best but I would look
for is how do i how do i pre sell
whatever you're trying to make how do
you get pre-orders whether using
Kickstarter a different platform your
own community whatever it is instead of
giving up equity in the business or
taking on a loan don't do that don't
start a business off a loan
I'd be looking at how can I get some
orders for what I'm providing and start
making some money doing that and trying
to bootstrap at the same time to build
my skills up to make something amazing
don't I wouldn't spend my time trying to
raise capital next
Daniel piece hey Evan thanks for your
work I'm 15 I love all the young man 15
years old 16 years I look at this like
man if I had this when I was 15 or 16
it'd be amazing just amazing for you
young entrepreneurs keep reaching out
like come to these live chats fill your
head with knowledge that is building you
up
whether it's my videos or ebooks or
podcasts or something else this is an
amazing opportunity for you to create so
much impact and wealth I'm so happy I
love the young entrepreneurs okay thank
you for your work I'm 15 I'd like to
know how can I find the topic for a
YouTube channel because I love all about
physiology but I'm on I'm not sure if
it's gonna work yet
okay so listen both most things don't
work out you're never gonna be sure if
it's gonna work out how do you how do
you how do you find out if it works out
you go off and you do it I'm much more
important than it working out at the
beginning is just back to the idea of
loving the process you have to love the
work so the trick for you is gonna be
okay you love physiology physiology
physiology or psychology anyway it
doesn't matter
I wrote physiology you love physiology
there's lots of YouTube chants about
physiology how are you gonna be
different what are you gonna combine is
gonna be different than what is
currently out there what do you want to
see I look at my channel as an example
if I when I started the top tens one of
the reasons was I wanted to be
surrounded by people who were doing much
bigger things in me you know I'm never
gonna meet Steve Jobs he's dead
that's not gonna happen I don't have
access to Elon Musk to hang out with him
and be his you know Protege for six
months so how do I surround myself with
these people i watch Elon Musk's videos
and in in 20 hours of videos you get 20
minutes of really good nuggets that I
can use because people asking them the
wrong questions because you know a lot
of the stuff is technical not
interesting to me but up 20 minutes
changed my life right it's massively
impactful I wish somebody just went out
there and took those 20 hours and
condensed it down to 20 minutes right
nobody did that so that's what I did out
of the problem came the opportunity and
whenever you find yourself saying I wish
somebody did this that's a good
opportunity for you to go off and make
it I didn't want to make my channel I
wish you made my channel I wish somebody
else did my channel there's a lot of
work I just want to consume to be
amazing that if somebody else made this
I could just watch it and be motivated
every day that would have been amazing
for me but nobody did it so that's what
I did so same thing for physiology
that's a great starting topic what do
you want to bring to it that nobody has
done before what's missing what do you
wish was available and then start
creating that and listen the first ones
will not work out the first ones will
not work out because right now you suck
and that's okay like expect to suck
don't expect to be great at the first
time you try anything you're gonna suck
nobody's gonna watch it your brand new
channel you won't get comments maybe
your friends your parents great send it
to me I'll leave a comment send it over
say Evan you promised you leave a
comment I'll go watch your video and
I'll leave a comment but expect a sock
it's gonna be terrible your first thing
is great and now I just have to get
better the next day and the next day and
the next day if you if you really love
making videos about physiology and you
find your niche the thing that makes you
separate and different and better then
eventually you will win you will win
you'll have the pivot a lot you have to
do a lot of experience but you're gonna
win good luck Eric Wayne Anderson Evan
my one word is respect thanks for your
book suggestion on how to discover a
business passion based off of my one
word so so you can apply to any your one
word is your core value so mine is
belief right it's who you are as a human
being you can bring that to any business
there's no one you're talking about was
it respect hold on respect respect is
needed in every business what business
doesn't need to have respect where are
you gonna win without respect in
business you need to have respect so you
can apply to anything now you have to
figure out what it is that you're
passionate about so I love entrepreneurs
I think entrepreneurs are gonna solve
all the world's major problems I don't
think it's corporations or governments
it's gonna be us we see problems we fix
it and because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur when I first started I
wanted to make the path a little bit
easier for other people coming down the
next generation so that's why I started
doing this I believe in entrepreneurs
but if it was an entrepreneurship I'd be
believing in somebody else a different
group that I'm passionate about so I
would just look at what are the what are
the ideas what it's the work that you
love doing you know you're you're
looking at the you're looking at the
values now you have to get to the how
right and it's gonna be looking at what
what makes you come alive take those
ideas that are in your head the best
thing is take the ideas are in your head
and just experiment on a small scale I
don't think people try enough things I
think everybody should try to be an
entrepreneur I think everybody should
try to be a youtuber I think everybody
should try to learn how to day in salsa
just like I think everybody should try
sushi and everybody should try pizza and
everybody should try a doughnut like you
need to try you need to try so you get a
sense for what it feels like and tastes
like until you find the thing that's
like yeah that was amazing I want to go
back to it and if you don't know what it
is that you want to do then you need to
expose yourself to as many opportunities
as possible to ultimately find the thing
that's gonna make you come alive don't
think you can't think your way through
it
guys sit on the couch and figure out
what your passion is and what your
business is gonna be you have to get out
there and experience things hey Evan I'm
12
Manny gets are you guys actually I feel
like every time I talk about age is
getting younger it's gonna be like hey
Evan I'm four okay I love it though if
you're 12 this is amazing Tony Robbins
is all about suffering okay how do you
build a business being happy all the
time I find it hard to motivate myself
if I'm happy I find it hard to motivate
myself if I'm happy right now
any ideas so I don't know the Tony
Robbins is all about suffering I think
he has both sides of it but we'll take
point as it is for now for me it's about
having a compelling vision like what do
you want to go off and do every time
that I think that I'm doing great
we talked about this earlier on my vlog
that you guys will see - every time I
think I'm doing great I remind myself of
how crappy I am and every time I feel
like crap I remind myself of how great I
am so there's that always that other
side that balance you out I default to
think how can I the basis love the base
for me is love like self-love I think
I'm amazing I think I'm a genius I think
I'm great I'm my favorite human being
who's your favorite human of all time
for me it's me and I hope for you it's
you
I think I'm great and I think I could be
greater my biggest fear in life is
regret that I'm gonna look back and be
90 100 200 however long we live and I'm
gonna say I wish I gave a little bit
more like I kind of mailed it in for
those three years I could have done
something bigger something better
something better that's my biggest fear
and so I'm always thinking how can I do
better right if you are around people
like Steve Jobs in Elon less and Oprah
you're you're they're pulling they pull
me up everybody on my channel pulls me
up to want to do more and so I'm by
default it's thinking what am I missing
how can I get stronger how do I hit the
next goal how do I have the big impact
that I want to have and so when I'm
talking to people about my channel and
what I'm trying to do it's always like I
need to I need to build a better team I
need to pick better topics I need to
have better research I need to be better
on camera and me myself personally and a
lot of times they say well you're too
hard on yourself like you've got so many
subscribers and so many views you're
doing a really good job and then I think
well what are you talking I'm amazing my
channel should have a Nobel Prize what
are you this is great aim I could do
more so it's having living in in both of
those worlds so if you are happy all the
time that's a fantastic place as a
foundation to start off but know that
you could be having a much bigger impact
you could be making other people a lot
more happy if you are just being happy
yourself and you're not spreading that
out to as many people as possible you're
being selfish and so it's looking at how
can you go off and have that bigger
impact so that when you are 90 or 100 or
200 you're not looking back saying I
wish I gave more of myself I believe if
you have the ability then you have
responsibilities so if you've the
ability to make others feel the
happiness that you feel then you have
the responsibility to spread that out as
wide as possible
hey Evan I'm ten I feel like you guys
are starting to chill me hard you know
[Laughter]
have you started business without money
I don't know how to start so I love this
if you're actually ten that's great my
son is almost nine so I imagine him
joining live chats and leaving questions
like this that'd be amazing you don't
need money to start a business I would
look at most of the companies that you
look up to the people look up to they
very often started without getting a
massive loan or investment from somebody
you have to understand that the ultimate
resource is your resourcefulness so it's
just taking the big idea that you have
and finding the smallest possible way to
get started so if you want to be a
youtuber and have a huge channel and you
want to have a production team and an
editor and you know ten people on your
business and that's your career that's
your that's your vision for yourself
great start now how do you start what's
the smallest possible way to get started
well you you take your phone and you
record your first video right just start
there's no perfect start whatever you
think if you're waiting for the perfect
start you're gonna be waiting forever
you will never find the perfect start
and that holds so many people back
they're seeking perfection and that
means they never actually do anything
and that that sunk my first business I
lost a 40 million dollar deal because we
tried to be perfect and ever since then
I've had to fight the perfectionism to
say no I just got to get something out
and then make it better and better and
better so you have the big dream that
motivates you of where you want to go of
the impact you want to have the money
you want to make the lives you're gonna
change amazing that should motivate and
inspire you and then break it down to
today what's the smallest possible
easiest way that I could do something
today with the skills and resources that
I have instead of focusing on all the
reasons why it's not going to work out
and all the resources you don't have
focus on the one way that it will work
out too many people are just looking for
those nose
they're looking for the the holes in the
plan instead of finding the one thing
that if they focused here they would
start the way
so look for the yes not to know next
paradigm shift travels thank you I was
working had some anxiety issues stop to
watch this feeling better already
live chat is awesome thank you for that
I'm not keeping super track of what's
happening to live chat but it's always
pretty awesome here believes nation
thank you for the love me LaVon when I'm
happy I'm not productive when I'm
frustrated I work 16 hours a day
okay so there's there's a the dark side
the frustration side the angry side can
definitely motivate you to work harder
you know you can you can deal with a lot
more pain a lot more frustration when
you are angry just like every every
superhero has this dark side and that's
what you know makes them motivate and
angry to go off and have a big impact
and fight that super villain but if you
live there all the time
ultimately I think you're gonna lose you
can't always be frustrated and unhappy
and angry a piece of you can like I I
have a piece of me that's always angry
that's always upset it's always looking
to push harder and do more this video
I'm upset that it's not better I'm upset
that I didn't give you more of myself
than I have today I'm upset always but
it's a small piece because net I'm happy
right and so I think the trick though is
when you are feeling happy most of the
time reminding yourself that you suck
reminding yourself that you should be
doing better reminding yourself that you
have so much more abilities and
capabilities in what you're showing
right now you need to remind yourself of
that so whenever you get a big win or
the day's amazing know that if you slack
off today you're not going to get closer
to you accomplishing the mission that
you have for yourself so if you have big
goals let's say if you don't have big
goals for yourself I don't know what to
tell you like if you are just happy if
you want to be a fisherman and fish all
day long in the Sun and enjoy life and
you're doing the thing you want to do
great like that's amazing I have no
advice for you but if you want to do
something bigger you want to have a
bigger impact you want to touch lives
and build an empire
then whatever you think is so great
right now like you're nowhere close
you're nowhere close you have to work
harder and so I will remind myself of
that constantly so hopefully that helps
gentleman Jenny Jenny Lynn I'm 35 years
old
all right yes I like that I like the I'm
not even though that is old but the
older entrepreneurs I'm 30 I'm 39 in 17
days I just committed to starting a new
business encouraging others to travel
any suggestions or come up with a
business name
oh Jenny Lynn I really hate this
question the business name doesn't
doesn't really matter it doesn't really
matter as long as it's not so you have
two options one you take something that
is that is already known that has an
association so if you if you call it
sailboat something or plane or you're
associated with it a current symbol that
people can adapt to then you're you're
leveraging that like if it's something
around playing or you have a logo of a
plane like we already associate what a
plane means right if you the other
option is you pick something that has no
meaning right it's it's it's it's Jenny
Lynn enterprises right like has no
meeting you're gonna assign the meaning
to it
those are those are two options the
worst option can do is one tell me what
you do like travel vlogging incorporated
right you may not want to be a vlogger
forever you may want to adjust your
business your boxing yourself in not
just for the audience your customers but
you're boxing yourself in of where you
think you can go so I wouldn't put what
I do in my company name and then if you
pick a symbol or a name that people have
negative associations with you know
something has nothing to do with travel
the the the Donald Trump travel company
you know like that may not be a great
name to call your new vlogging web site
but apart from that it's not a huge it's
not a big deal what's my company name
who cares right I'm upset because like
this is our time together this is this
is our two three four minutes
and I wish it I could give you advice on
something that would more meaningfully
move the ball forward for you because a
company name whether you call yourself a
B C Corp or big microphone Corp or I
love coffee like it's not going to make
a huge difference compared to all the
other decisions that you have to do in
your business so anyway I hope the
answer helped and good luck on the
company I'm excited
crazy-cool creations do youtubers have
to pay taxes yes
youtubers have to pay taxes you make
money you have to pay taxes you can move
to a different country or a different
city while different country there's
different tax laws of YouTube buddy of
mine is really seriously looking at
moving to Puerto Rico because it's still
part of the United States but their tax
laws are different than mainland so you
have to give up his right to vote and a
couple other things but we kissed the
weather and doesn't have to pay as many
taxes so yeah you still hope you still
pay taxes the the government can audit
you they check your bank account right
if you need us the IRS cares how much
you're making so yes
youtubers have to pay taxes you sell
anything legitimately you have to pay
taxes
dirty mint you're gonna be 39 in 17 days
you look good I thought you were 10
years younger yes but I also don't care
you think thank you for the love I know
is that I love I'm just we're going on a
rant early this morning about not caring
about other people's opinions Nick
Fleming
I'm 24 this is the thing that
everybody's giving their age I started
the business and gave a partner 50%
what's coming next
now I realize I build the business he
doesn't do anything unless I tell him
exactly and hound him get rid of get rid
of her push him get rid of yeah and and
either if you have some way out that's
easy that's great like ideally come to
an understanding that this is this is
what he would need to do and he doesn't
want to do that and you have different
visions for the business and you could
just walk away that's the ideal
situation I don't know how much is
really built into the business from you
know how much is the company worth if
it's worth anything your other option
just be shut
down and then start a new business all
on your own which is more expensive more
time-consuming legal you got to get a
new company set up all that kind of
stuff so ideally you have a conversation
you both come to an agreement and he
moves on listen I had to fire my best
friend my best friend from high school
was one of the first guys that I hired
for my company I had a website and he
was writing content for the website and
he was just too slow he would take
painstaking hours to get like the the
right word and the white right sentence
every single time and I loved the
attention to detail on the amount of
quality that went into it but I needed
someone who could make good content
faster you know he was writing
Shakespearean level stuff it's not what
I needed for the website and it ended up
causing both of us stress like I'm I'm
unhappy that I'm not getting the content
that I need at the pace that I need and
he's upset that he's letting me down and
and feeling stress and rushed and it's
not how he works and end up just having
a discussion like this is not this is
not a fit for what we both want now he
wasn't a partner in my business but it
just came down to a conversation and it
made sense for him to exit and we're
still friends so you can do it it's just
being not putting blame and not getting
defensive and not getting angry and
yelling and just trying to understand
the other person and having the clear
vision before you want to go and having
a real conversation about it I think too
many people jump into a 50/50 business
partnership way too soon I think in so
many partnerships one person brings way
more than the other person and everybody
talks a big game at the beginning yeah
I'll do this I'll do this and you do
that and it's going to be beautiful and
you have these skills and I have these
skills it's gonna work out amazing it
very rarely happens like that you need
to spend as much time with your business
partner as you do thinking about who
you're gonna marry because you're you're
spending more time with your business
partner than you are with your husband
or wife and it's crazy how people jump
into a business relationship and be
50/50 partners barely knowing the other
person where if you're gonna marry
somebody you're gonna date them and
you're gonna go out and you're gonna
and months or years getting to know them
so best advice there is if you're
thinking about bringing another partner
just start on one project you might have
a shared vision for what you want to
build great start working together on
something just find one thing to work
together on that he's gonna do this and
you're gonna do that or she's gonna do
this and you're gonna do that and just
see how well do you work together was
that fun do I want to go back and do it
again do I want to spend the next 30
years of my life side-by-side with whose
person building something amazing and if
not then then move on if you can't enjoy
the people that you're with and they're
not pulling their weight you don't want
to be in a business with them they may
be great friends afterwards they may be
people you can contract some work out to
but they don't need to be your your
business partner spend more time
edgy wedgy all right I like it I'm in
junior year of high school and don't
really enjoy school I've wanted out of
business for longest time without what
mean compromising my grades is it worth
it this is a tough one
I would I would default for me
personally because I still liked having
school as a back-up plan that I would do
my best to get the grades that I needed
and start my business on the side I
think you have time for everything I
would I would sacrifice I would
sacrifice friends I would sacrifice the
personal life I would sacrifice
scrolling through Instagram and snapchat
and Facebook and YouTube
I would really add it my time and see am
i spending in the right spots that
helped me with my academic career as
well as with my business listen with
academics you there's always even if
it's as a back-up plan there's always
ways to like if you just focus and study
the material you can do well it doesn't
have to take an insane amount of time
unless you have some kind of learning
disability it doesn't have to take as
much time just a lot of times when
people are spending time focusing on
studying they're not actually focused in
studying like if you sat down and we're
studying for four hours how much of the
time are you actually studying versus
figuring out what playlist you're gonna
put on in your phone and checking all
your notifications that are coming up
and thinking about what you're gonna be
doing tomorrow like you're not actually
focused in those four hours of studying
and so I would try to do both
the general answer for everybody like
you have multiple things you want to do
and you're not sure which path is going
to be the best for you I would try to do
both and just focus on actually
executing them well instead of being
distracted by all the crap in your life
it's a tough question to answer about
whether to continue on an education or
not because it really comes down to
self-awareness do you know like for the
rest of your life that you do not want
to be working for somebody else
some people might know that in junior of
high school do you might know for sure
like I meant to be an entrepreneur
hundred percent no regrets
I'm gonna go all-in and some people have
dropped out and gone and done it I did
not have the self-awareness to know that
that early on and so that's the reason
for the hedge you know if there's any
piece of you that is doubting then I
would look at how do I get absolute
certainty around it it's not that you
can't come back and do high school when
you're 40 you can it's just really sucks
really sucks so for education I would I
wouldn't shut the door--and until I was
100% certain whew guys I don't know a
lot more questions coming in it's been
an hour thank you for the love it's been
a ton of fun I will try to do this again
next week I am in where am I I'm in
Philadelphia or California somewhere
next week so I may not be able to do it
it's actually not on the schedule so
we're probably not going to do it but
I'll see if I can sneak it in
listen it's it's what noon for me here
in Toronto whatever time zone you're in
I want you to try to take this energy
today and pour it into something that
you're gonna be proud of if I've given
you anything today that you have learned
and you're at all increased in
motivation or energy I want you to make
something today that you're proud of
that today you're gonna make something
however long you have left in the day
whether it's 12 hours or 30 minutes
before you go to bed you still have time
if you're in bed get out of bed and do
one thing that you're gonna be proud of
that you want to show your grandkids and
say today May 3rd 2018 I made this so go
do that thank you guys - love I believe
in you hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love see you soon
you